make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
hello everyone how's everybody doing
welcome to how much explain in this
video yes in this video we are covering
Biondo mega level once again and we're
talking about a character that honestly
I can't believe we waited this long to
cover in this series this Silver Surfer
now the Silver Surfer was created by
Jack Kirby and made his first appearance
in Fantastic Four number 48 and 1966
which I actually have a copy of and the
actual creation of the Silver Surfer is
pretty interesting so back in the 1960s
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby created comics
using a process called the Marvel method
where Stanley would give Kirby a general
outline of an issues plot Kirby would
then draw the issue and give it back to
Stan who would then add in the narration
in the dialogue now when Kirby turned in
his pencils for issue number 48 they
included a character the carribean Lee
had not discussed which of course was
the Silver Surfer and Jack Kirby decided
that since Galactus was a god-like
entity he would need a herald and since
he was tired of drawing spaceships he
decided to put him on a surfboard
now despite being taken totally by
surprised Stanley actually loved the
design of the character so much that he
just rolled with it and the Silver
Surfer became a mainstay in the Marvel
Universe kind of a fun little fun fact
now as for his in continuity origin as
most of you guys know the Silver Surfer
is the alter ego of Norrin Radd a
citizen of the planet zenn-la a planet
that has basically become a utopia
having eliminated all diseases famines
war and crime but achieving perfection
came at a cost in the bazillion people
basically found themselves with a lot of
idle time and nothing to do now this
leaves Norns mother el mar rad to end up
taking her own life basically and later
his father would follow suit after it
was revealed that he'd stolen the
intellectual property of another
scientist leading to his disgrace and so
Norns early life was plagued by
unspeakable tragedy but eventually
everything changed for him as in law
suddenly found itself in the crosshairs
of Galactus who had marked the planet
for consumption
now Noren strikes a deal with Galactus
who agrees to spares in law in exchange
for Noren serving as his Herald and
finding planets for him to consume and
as part of this bargain Galactus gives
Norn a portion of the power cosmic which
is a super powerful cosmic energy that
seems to originate from Galactus himself
and as a result Noren is transformed
into the Silver Surfer and travels
throughout the cosmos on a surfboard to
find planets for his master to consume
now as we get into the silver surfers
powers it's really hard to narrow them
down
to a definitive list because the power
cosmic is really just a plot devices
used to explain why Galactus and as
heralds are so powerful and so for that
reason it's hard to really come up with
a definitive list of what it allows its
users to do as the real answer is that
it's whatever the story dictates that
the character needs to do the power
cosmic will simply allow them to do so
and so while the list of powers were
about to go over is long it is
definitely by no means exhaustive and so
first of all the Silver Surfer possesses
superhuman strength with no upper limit
and is among the physically strongest
characters in the Marvel Universe having
gone toe-to-toe with the Hulk and Thanos
broken through a wall made of vibranium
which is practically indestructible and
even pushed a moon into Galactus the
Silver Surfer skin makes him practically
invulnerable allowing him to not only
take punches from the Hulk and Thor
and/or the crushing weight of an entire
planet made of stone but also shake off
a blast from ego the Living Planet and
on another occasion a blast from all six
Infinity stones now also a blast from
michael korvac was said to be able to
melt the entire planet and had no effect
on the Silver Surfer at all the silver
surfers durability is so high in fact
that he was able to survive travelling
to the center of stars without
sustaining any injuries furthermore even
though it is incredibly difficult to
harm the surfer in the event that he is
harmed he's able to heal from any injury
and can also heal the wounds of others
including mortal injuries in a play that
had infected thousands the surfer can
also survive without food water air or
sleep which is pretty essential when
you're traveling through the vacuum of
space all the time and has been able to
survive inside of a black hole he's
capable of phasing through solid objects
reading minds and also possesses
telekinesis the Silver Surfer can travel
at many times the speed of light
reaching speeds of five hundred thousand
light-years per second and has even
traveled so fast that he broke the time
barrier allowing him to travel through
time at will the Silver Surfer also
possesses cosmic awareness which allows
him to sense basically everything in the
universe from changes in the chemical
makeup of a single beam to the removal
of an entire planet from a solar system
now the most impressive feats of the
silver surfers power however come from
his ability to manipulate matter and
energy he can change the molecular
composition of any object or individual
into any form he chooses he's even able
to take matter and transform it into
pure energy which he can then manipulate
in a variety of forms one of the many
forms this takes is an powerful energy
blast that this
surfer uses against his opponents these
blasts are so powerful that they're able
to destroy meteors large spacecraft and
even entire planets on one occasion the
surfer produced a blast so powerful that
it matched the power of the soul stone
which would require a massive amount of
energy the Silver Surfer also uses his
ability to manipulate energy defensively
and can create force fields powerful
enough to block nuclear explosions the
god blast of Thor and cosmic radiation
the surfer can also absorb a seemingly
limitless amount of energy having
drained the Hulk of all the gamma
radiation in his body and turning him
back into Bruce Banner absorbing the
energy of a star and harnessing it to
destroy a moon and taking out an entire
solar system after siphoning energy from
the you know Lord one of the most
powerful enemies in the history of
Marvel aiding the surfer in his duties
as both a Herald of Galactus and during
a subsequent time as a superhero is the
surf board made up of cosmic energy that
he travels on but the board is really
much more than just a simple means of
conveyance the board was able to destroy
a planet-sized asteroid that was
hurtling toward Earth and it can also
shift into virtually any shape including
a sword large enough to battle the
symbiote god no the surfer can also
imprison beings within the board even
beings as powerful as the former Captain
Marvel genus Val who actually used his
power to warp the entirety of reality
not just to highlight a couple more of
his more impressive feats on one
occasion this surfer was able to bathe
the entire earth with enough cosmic
energy to impact every single person and
temporarily bring about world peace the
issue with that is actually in this
story Silver Surfer Requiem which isn't
necessarily in continuity this is by no
means a comprehensive list of the silver
surfers accomplishments he's been around
for over 50 years and frequently goes up
against some of the most powerful
entities in the Marvel Universe so he's
constantly proving himself to be an
extremely strong character that's
definitely deserving of being placed in
the beyond Omega level category and if
you still don't believe me just remember
the Silver Surfer was part of the
annihilators and that really just kind
of speaks for itself
right a team that would pretty much
decimate any superhero team in existence
in Marvel Comics without being said guys
for to bring this video to an end if you
are new here - comments explained make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]